Colbert Jimmy one Jimmy two I've called
you all here for one important reasons
to listen up you can't shoot any more
late night shows here in our beautiful
overly expensive studio so
congratulations you're all youtubers now
meet your new audience boys hey there
sport you like jokes about politics and
Karen it's film theory with Stephen
Colbert Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel
generic image of a man generic image of
a woman and of course your host of
two-dimensional cutouts vaguely animated
to have emotion hello internet welcome
to film Theory living in strange times
aren't we
handshakes aren't cool anymore we're not
just allowed but encouraged to be
wearing face masks into places you
probably shouldn't be wearing face masks
normally like gas stations banks and
liquor stores and most strangely of all
late-night television shows are doing
something unheard of they're being
forced to change let me give you a
little bit of backstory here it was 1954
when tonight starring Steve Allen the
precursor to The Tonight Show first hit
the national airwaves at the time the
concept of a live late-night show was so
fresh so new that Steve Allen basically
had to explain to his national audience
what they were seeing in the first
episode that was actually a live picture
you were looking at that was not movie
film you know we're actually seeing Time
Square here in New York City but
audiences in 2020 need no explanation
mostly because they've been watching the
exact same formula for 64 years this is
that 1954 broadcast
and this is from this year let's try
this actually this might be fun let's
turn the screen black and white
wheeze in that aspect ratio had a bit of
that old-time graininess to it and
lastly Josi audio master let's crank up
that treble and turn down that bass now
let's play this whole thing again it is
just like the 50s sure we have better
cameras and sound but the formula is
still the same then just does it start
to feel like late night shows would
continue doing their best impressions of
a 50s era variety show for the rest of
eternity everything changed in the blink
of an eye early March 2020 with social
distancing orders imminent in California
New York many late night shows announced
that they would continue shooting
episodes in studio but without the
studio audience present only people the
eyes right now are some members of my
staff hi guys almost immediately
thereafter many of those same shows
changed their minds and elected to
suspend production outright in order to
protect their staff and crews which
makes sense because the staff and crews
of these late-night shows are massive I
mean get a load of how many people are
credited on Colbert's January tenth
episode alone if you're counting along
at home that is 23 writing credits 39
producer credits who knew that it took
that many people to rip off youtuber
formats
Bondi Beach that'd be fun
then one by one the late night shows all
reemerged in their quarantine forms
these episodes had severely pared down
production values and were shot from the
hosts homes while in quarantine
celebrity guests started dropping by via
videoconference the hosts own family
stepped in as iPhone camera operators
and recurring guests said when my wife
is a cameraman my crew is still one of
my children tonight it is my son John
which I just say is a bit curious
because all the big late-night programs
are Union productions
it's skeptical that Colbert's
college-age son is a card-carrying
member of Yahtzee and I doubt Fallon's
kids who are again a bunch of screen
time these days are up on their sag
after a rules or that cop is okay with
the amount of work they're putting into
their productions but hey you know I
could be wrong the point here is that
god with the slick sets gone with the
studio bands gone with the couches and
desks and audiences required to laugh at
every mundane tired Joe overnight
late-night talk show hosts got turned
into low-budget youtubers and as any
homegrown youtuber will tell ya it means
that they've been left with no safety
nets to protect them against the biggest
fear of them all the cringe
[Music]
has there been a lot of cringe so today
as a homespun youtuber myself I'm
analyzing their performance which
late-night celebrity turned out to be
the best youtuber what lessons do they
need to learn while working out of their
at home studios and what does all of
this mean for the future of late-night
programming outside of me never getting
invited on to one of these shows ever
because everyone's gonna be bitter at me
about this episode sorry not sorry
before we dive in a little housekeeping
up front there are a whole lot of late
night shows out there so I'm gonna have
to limit today's conversation to the
following list Jimmy Kimmel Stephen
Colbert James Corden Jimmy Fallon Seth
Meyers Conan O'Brien and Trevor Noah
we're only gonna look at major US
late-night shows that have transitioned
to doing quarantine version episodes of
their show from home multiple times per
week so if a show isn't producing new
episodes at the moment or only did one
episode a week to begin with well then
they're not part of today's discussion
so with all that out of the way I've
taken the liberty of pouring through
hours and hours of these new low-budget
quarantine version episodes here's where
your friendly neighborhood YouTube coach
Matt Pat is seen across the board first
off I am seeing some really unflattering
camera angles there people you are
professionals you are adults you are
trained in this industry we're trying to
decrease the number of chins not
increase them people so let's get that
camera eye level or higher Kimmel Conan
what are you doing we understand that
you don't have wardrobe makeup or hair
departments at the moment nobody is
faulting you for that but you can
absolutely get your camera up at eye
level points off for both of you
gentlemen next up let's talk delivery
there's something to be said for
sticking with what you do best but then
again when you actually see some of
these late night hosts delivering jokes
the exact same way that they do to a
live studio audience well that's when
the cringe really starts to set in
you're talking to a camera not a theater
filled with live bodies who are forced
to react to everything that you say Seth
Meyers is especially guilty of holding
four laughs when there's no studio
audience president the Treasury
Department has ordered that President
Trump's name will be printed on relief
checks which would be the first time
he's ever put his name on something
helpful
man there are no laughs coming my friend
everyone is always eager to make fun of
how frenetic youtubers are with their
smash cuts every few seconds there's a
reason for that the internet runs at a
mile a minute and pauses in this
universe are used to show that something
is awkward not that something is funny
you let it sit and hang because it's
uncomfortable
memes graphics sound effects these are
the things that punctuate jokes and
service transitions filling the gaps in
where a laugh track would normally be
granted delivering a joke to an empty
room as an ideal I know that as well as
anybody but when you're delivering jokes
out of your poorly lit living room the
presentation of your jokes kind of needs
to match your surroundings points to
Jimmy Kimmel for actually recognizing
this thing and adjusting accordingly
back in mid-march Kimmel was doing many
logs basically the exact kind of
stand-up jokes that you'd see in a fully
produced show in studio and he was doing
it seated at his desk here's something I
learned did you know that you can make
coffee at home for yourself I even
spelled my name right on the cup I'm not
saying that it's a bad joke I'm saying
that it's written and delivered in a way
that doesn't match the medium it's being
delivered through when you see someone
face to the camera vlogging to a lens in
an unlit youtube video there's a certain
expectation that the audience has
whether they can articulate it or not
that you're about to do something wrong
you're about to go off script something
conversational and unpolished as opposed
to fully scripted and crafted and it
seems like Kimmel and his team did
eventually get the memo because come
April he was back to delivering his
monologue on his feet on a homemade set
with production values slightly more
aligned with his more polished jokes
TLDR when the cameras not angled up
Kimmel's nostrils everyone wins the long
and short of it is that the medium and
the message have to align are you doing
an up-close hand-held vlog style video
well then you have to make it raw
unpolished a bit more off-the-cuff you
need to stay on script well in that case
have it be a bit more polished and
presentational stand up find a nice
backdrop that serves as a sort of set
you know who's crushing it right now
someone who is never a late-night host
John Krasinski and a show some good news
which takes the homespun appeal infuse
it with the polish of a more scripted
format so I got to give the w of this
episode wait some good news was bought
by Viacom and John Krasinski is no
longer hosting and it's going behind the
CBS all access pay wall that is some bad
news right there also real galaxy brain
idea there Viacom let's buy this thing
that was successful for being raw and
organic and homespun and free and
eliminate the host his family and I
would guess all of the homemade elements
that made it popular in the first place
which it's worth noting was also less
than ten episodes many of which had
massive reunions of huge casts for
celebrity cameos which you know would
kind of artificially inflate those
numbers but you know what whatever I'm
sure that people will pay for a show
that they were watching for free that
they literally just learned about less
than a few weeks ago all right so with
that W very quickly turned into an L
second place goes to Trevor Noah and the
daily show unlike his late-night Piers
Noah is embracing all sorts of classic
battle-tested youtuber tactics that
stave off the cringe unlike his in
studio show Noah's the daily distancing
show really has the feel of a YouTube
video for one thing he freely uses JPEGs
and sound effects to aid in his jokes
while the rest of us are trying to
figure out if we can grow tomatoes by
planting some ketchup spoiler alert you
can in fact the daily distancing show
applies all sorts of YouTube style
editing tricks to inject energy we're
talking jump cuts pushing into tighter
angles doing conversations with yourself
as different characters people even do
it with jokes oh my god Nigerians are
funny Indians this is the kind of stuff
that top youtubers pioneered on the
platform over a decade ago
I mean this is YouTube 101 stuff here
people top youtubers were doing this in
2008 and in 2013 and you know we're
still doing it in 2020 and finally
traditional media is like huh this is an
interesting idea but of course all of
this is just my opinion right what I
really want to know is whether the
numbers agree with me if Trevor Noah's
doing so great with his new at home show
that riffs on a bunch of YouTube tropes
while other hosts aren't then the
numbers would presumably be able to
confirm that
so let's look at the Nielsen ratings and
gospel stats for each of the little
shows in our list what I'm curious about
is how the TV ratings YouTube views and
youtube subscriber numbers for each of
the shows have fared during the pandemic
to give us a baseline let's look at each
shows numbers at the end of January
immediately before the global health
crisis was announced on January 30th
this should give us a sense of how each
late night show was doing on TV as well
as on YouTube back in the good old days
before we were all locked and our little
prisons
so with those January numbers at hand
let's compare him against the first
month of quarantine version late night
shows March 20th through April 20th when
we crunch the numbers the heat map looks
a little something like this
first takeaway from the data set none of
the late night show YouTube channels
gained more views during the quarantine
in fact most experienced a significant
decrease in total views that strikes me
as super weird because YouTube hasn't
been getting a ton of traffic during the
quarantine so much so in fact that
YouTube has had to lower video quality
on the site in order to handle the surge
of viewership perhaps the quarantine
versions of late night shows were a bit
too homemade for the subscribers tastes
whatever the reason though it seems like
the kings of late-night broadcasts are
not yet the kings of new media broadcast
second takeaway I got to give myself a
big old Matt pat on the back for this
one The Daily Show with Trevor Noah
is killing it compared to his peers
their YouTube views have stayed stagnant
but look at that surge in subscribership
during the first 30 days of quarantine
he got four hundred and seventy thousand
new subscribers that's more than any
other late-night youtube channel accrued
during that time and the Daily Show's
YouTube channel is much much smaller
than some of the other late-night
channels out there
what's more the Daily Show with Trevor
Noah is gaining more subscribers per
month in quarantine than they were in
January so no matter how you slice it
the YouTube viewers are subscribing to
the daily show like they never have
before most likely because it's the only
one of these shows that's actually
speaking in the language of YouTube but
of course that's just YouTube surely a
show like that wouldn't resonate with
broadcast audiences on the TV right
wrong believe it or not the daily
distancing show saw such a spike in
broadcast viewership that the show's
total viewers season average jumped 28
percent in under three months that's
right by shooting a low-budget version
of the
at home Trevor Noah and his team have
actually improved their television
ratings dramatically conversely take a
look at the subscription column of our
handy heat map falen Corden Colbert not
only were these shows unable to maintain
their subscribership rates they saw a
drop in subscribers during a remarkably
high traffic period of time in YouTube
history on the television side their
numbers either didn't fluctuate at all
or they only saw incremental increases
nothing compared to what The Trevor Noah
show is doing so the question becomes
what does all of this mean why is any of
this important I mean if a late-night
host like Trevor Noah can make the show
out of his living room and actually gain
ground on his late-night peers not only
on YouTube but in broadcast as well
maybe there are some lessons here that
late-night shows can take to heart what
might those lessons be well I got some
theories theory one guests won't
physically come into the studio as often
when the late-night shows it away within
studio celebrity guests for a month
their broadcast ratings weren't hurt so
maybe it's time to re-examine whether
contemporary audiences need or expect
their celebrity guests to actually be in
studio other industries are figuring out
that telecommuting can work
why not late night theory number two
late night shows will see their budgets
start to shrink networks love saving
money in fact a big reason why the
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon moved
to New York after Jay Leno retired was
because the show could save twenty
million dollars annually on tax credits
and the quarantine has helped highlight
a couple of areas where costs could get
trimmed but here's the biggest and most
important takeaway theory number three
digital is indeed the future we've
talked about it for years now about how
YouTube is paving the way for
entertainment and I've made no small
deal about how I'm pro team internet
over here but here is your proof in the
pudding right now traditional media the
numbers don't lie one of the oldest
television show formats in history start
showing better numbers when they started
producing like youtubers and not just on
YouTube but also undrawn cast television
popular opinion is changing what people
want to watch is evolving audiences are
looking for something different
some good news is yet another example of
that the times they are a-changin the
question is traditional media are you
willing to change with it at the very
least are you just gonna give us
youtubers some respect finally because
you all seem to be failing pretty hard
when it comes to do an hour job but hey
that's just a theory
a film theory and subscribe so that my
numbers can actually trash the numbers
of those late night shows that's it hit
the subscribe button right now show
traditional media that yes youtubers
can't produce stuff that people want to
watch people want to subscribe to and
that is valuable to me as an audience
regardless of what screen it's on your
subscription on today's video is a big
screw you to them so stick it to the man
guys